[SQUEAKING]
[RUSTLING] [CLICKING]
MARKUS KLUTE: Welcome to 8701.
My name is Markus Klute.
I'm going to be your
instructor for this class.
This class is taught in
an inverted classroom,
a flipped classroom environment.
So this is the very
first of a large number
of small, short videos, which
[INAUDIBLE] is the contents
of slides I've prepared.
For this first slide,
it's not necessary
that you even watch
the video, because they
should explain themselves.
And I will not give you too
much additional information.
As we go deeper
into the content,
that's not quite the case.
And that might be useful
for you to watch the videos,
learn, stop, record a
number of questions, so
if some of the problems which I
pose on the slides, and so on.
So this is the very first one.
And the idea of
this sort of slide
is to just give you a
quick overview of what
to expect for this class.
The first thing we
look at is the calendar
for the fall semester.
The summer ended
much more quickly
than we were all hoping for.
The weather is still very nice
out there, but fall is coming.
So Tuesday, September
1st, we'll meet and greet
in the first session.
That session is
really just meant
for an overview of the course
organization, and so on.
So this kind of information
as I give in this video
will be very briefly covered
on that Tuesday, as well.
As you can see
from the calendar,
we meet Tuesday and Thursday.
The meeting or the
visitation starts at 1:30 PM.
I aim for one hour in
each of those meetings,
but we can stay a little longer,
even half an hour longer,
if there's open questions
or need for discussion.
This semester will give us a
few holidays along the way.
There's Columbus Day, where
Tuesday is a student holiday.
I will not have a
recitation on Election Day.
I want you to focus
on the election,
and I will focus on it myself.
And then there is the
week of Thanksgiving
where we will not
have any meeting,
any class during that week.
You can also see that
there is a number of PSets
in the second week.
We'll post a PSet, and I'll
give you about two weeks
to respond to that PSet.
More on how we
evaluate in this class
in a different recording--
just to say here
already that there's
going to be two oral
exams towards the middle
of the semester and towards
the end, very short,
little test, 15
minutes per student.
We will set up individual
meetings to go over this.
And then there is Friday
as an office hour.
I haven't specified
the time for this yet.
I sent you a Doodle poll.
And we'll find the time
which works for most of you
on a Friday afternoon
or Friday morning.
This class doesn't have
a final, so it basically
ends with the last
day of class, which
is oral exams in the
15th week of this class.
Looking a little bit
into the content,
the first week is
really an introduction
and some historic remarks.
We'll talk about
relativistic kinematics.
And then we'll go
along the outline as
given in one of our textbooks.
Again, textbooks are
being discussed yet
in a different
short presentation.
But I really follow
along this textbook,
but not stick too much to only
the content of that textbook.
And I will supplement
the information
using other textbooks,
as well, specifically
when it comes to some of the
problems and discussions which
come along.
You can see that we'll
start with particle physics,
talk about quarks,
leptons, and interactions,
talk about how this fits
in a theoretical way
with invariance principle
and conservation laws.
And we'll look at
scattering, and then
QCD before we go into
weak interaction.
And from there on, we
build the standard model
with the electroweak
interaction, the Higgs
mechanisms.
For week eight, then,
or the end of week eight
will give us a break,
where we then start
talking about nuclear physics.
This order of talking about
particle physics and then
nuclear physics makes
a lot of sense to me.
It doesn't make sense
in historic context,
because nuclear
physics have developed
before the standard model,
for example, was developed.
But in order to fully
appreciate nuclear physics,
it's useful to have
introduced basic interactions.
And therefore, this is
the reason for this order.
And then we'll try to bring
in experimental methods
with accelerators, colliding
beams, and experimental methods
on how particles interact
with matter and detectors.
Again, in this schedule, the
Thanksgiving week is off.
And we'll use the
last remaining week
to discuss physics
beyond the standard model
and the connection to cosmology.
I said here the title the
schedule will be tuned.
I very much expect that we have
a little bit slippage in this,
but there is some
room at the end
to make sure that
we don't overrun,
and that I don't give you
too much to learn, to read,
to watch movies, or do
PSets as we go week by week.
This is it for this
first recording.
As always, you can reach out
and ask any sort of question,
either during the recitation,
office hours, or separate.